you
I is a master chef and about twice a
week she and her boyfriend Matt host a
group of strangers at their home in
Williamsburg Brooklyn to enjoy a gourmet
Japanese meal their guests find them
through a website called eat width which
makes it possible to book a reservation
for a meal not at a restaurant but in
someone's home each gas phase I in Matt
a fee of $41 and eat with takes a 15%
cut they have fantastic kooky and unique
and beautiful loft here in Brooklyn and
they're just interesting and vivacious
and lovely and the food is just beyond
eat width which is now in 30 countries
won't divulge its sales numbers but the
company says it has thousands of open
applications from potential hosts and
that its volume is rapidly growing when
you come to a dining event through with
there's the element of the social and
human experience that you're just not
going to get anywhere else around a
table sit strangers and friends together
great food a glass of wine a good
conversation magical things are going to
happen it may look like a dinner party
but this is an underground supper club
held on the Lower East Side
clandestine dinner parties like these
have become more common in New York City
and insiders tell us they are completely
unregulated they should be regulated by
the same system that regulates every
restaurant in New York City when it
aired back in September this story by
New York CBS affiliate was widely mocked
for its alarmist tone you guys are
breaking a law by serving people meals
and charging the notion that government
should regulate dinner parties seem so
preposterous the journalist compared the
story to a fake news report you might
see in the onion but it's not all that
far-fetched
if these homegrown restaurants become
more common the city might start issuing
fines that would force hosts like Matt
and I at a business New York City
Department of Health spokesperson
Veronica Lewin told Bloomberg
Businessweek people offer meals to the
public for money need permit
the city does not allow meals to be
served to members of the public in
someone's home guy Michelin is he with
schoo founder and CEO he says the
company is trying to work with local
governments to set up regulations for
home dining if you're doing it everyday
then I guess there should be some kind
of regulation because you're on the
spectrum you are getting closer to
becoming a restaurant so the question is
where the line process and this is
something we will need to work with a
regulator in every city we're coming to
define the framework and to define where
the line should cross Michelin has hired
a law firm to work with local regulators
to come up with a pathway for making
home dining legal but why should the
government have any say over what people
eat or charge for in the privacy of
their own dining rooms unlike at a
restaurant eat with guests get to
socialize with the person cooking their
meal and the kitchen is often wide open
for everyone to see how the food is
being handled and prepared the
peer-to-peer economy the sharing economy
is changing paradigms I have no doubt
that there's a real hunger for more
human interactions and it's those real
connecting experiences that will linger
with a guest for much longer after the
dinner is ended
you